bonsoir à tous Bienvenue ça vous regarde
en direct notre grand témoin ce soir
vous la reconnaissez c'est Roselyne
Bachelot qui cartonne en librairie et
qui fustige le bal des hypocrites dans
son dernier livre 680 de jour dans les
coulisses du ministère de la Culture en
plein covid s'attirent à vue et comme
souvent c'est mordant et plein
d'enseignements vont en parler tout à
l'heure on a une heure ensemble pour
décrypter l'actualité de ce mercredi 18
janvier au sommaire ce soir la bataille
des retraites bien sûr la vague de la
mobilisation demain s'annonce haute voir
très haute journée de tous les dangers
pour le gouvernement de toutes les
opportunités pour les syndicats de la
relancer la vitalité des grandes
centrales dans le pays on en débat dans
un instant avec nos invités et puis aux
alentours de 20h15 vous rendez vous les
cartes blanches de nos affranchis et
puis le bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée ce soir les premiers
frondeurs en macronie voilà vous savez
tout vous me suivez dans une Bachelot
absolument ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
et revoilà le spectre de la France
bloquée demain sera donc à non pas
douter une journée noire dans le secteur
public veiller d'armes pour les
syndicats qui jouent gros et qui
espèrent une nouvelle santé dans ce bras
de fer bonsoir Christopher Weissberg
merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Français établis en
Amérique du Nord en face de vous Arthur
de Laporte bonsoir bienvenue député
socialiste du Calvados bonsoir
Jean-Claude Mailly figure maintenant
régulière dans cette émission et ancien
secrétaire général de Force Ouvrière
j'imagine que vous suivez ce mouvement
de très près tout comme vous
Jean-François Mathieu bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes sociologue du
travail et spécialiste des mouvements
sociaux Roselyne Bachelot les syndicats
vous connaissez vous en parlez
d'ailleurs dans votre bouquin évidemment
vous êtes libre d'intervenir quand vous
le souhaitez dans dans ce débat à quoi
peut-on s'attendre demain on a déjà pas
mal d'indicateurs Stéphane lakowski à
200 secondes pour nous en parler le
chrono de la côte tout de suite
et on se retourne pour vous écouter
durant votre mode restreint bonsoir
bonsoir madame la ministre bonsoir
monsieur qui est un peu plus loin alors
à quoi peut-on s'attendre demain je ne
sais pas si vous êtes au courant mais
l'union fait la force ce n'est pas
seulement la devise de la Belgique comme
vous pouvez le vérifier l'union fait la
force c'est aussi la devise de la
Malaisie de l'Angola de la Bolivie on en
apprend des trucs sur LCP alors si je
pense à ça c'est parce que ça pourrait
aussi être de ta devise des syndicats
demain face à la réforme l'union fait la
force je vous montre un document
rarissime
oui syndicats qui ont signé un même
document ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 12
ans donc d'un côté ça souligne la
caractère exceptionnel de cette
mobilisation de demain et en même temps
on se rappelle qu'il y a 12 ans c'était
en 2010 et malgré la mobilisation
exceptionnelle la réforme des retraites
était passées donc bon moi je dois dire
que on se rendent de mal à mobilisation
devrait quand même importante ça c'est
pas la question j'ai juste un document
pour ceux qui auraient un doute c'est
sur la carte de la CFDT on voit le point
où sont prévus les rassemblements donc
là on a vraiment le sentiment que la
France sera couverte de manif mais la
vraie question c'est pas vraiment demain
on pense que le succès sera présent
c'est plutôt est-ce que ça va tenir dans
la durée parce que dans le communiqué de
l'intersyndicale que je vous ai montré
que je vous montre en entier il y a une
phrase qui est importante et qui dit que
les manifs de demain ce n'est que le
départ d'une puissante mobilisation sur
les retraites dans la durée alors
combien de temps vais tenter de vous
rappeler l'Union pardon la devise de la
Bolivie et aussi de l'engueula l'union
fait la force est-ce que les syndicats
vont réussir à rester unis c'est leur
grande force aujourd'hui si demain il se
divise bien forcément ils vont
s'affaiblir et donc le problème c'est
que parmi les syndicats tout le monde
n'a pas forcément la même approche du
syndicalisme par exemple Laurent Berger
je vais retrouver une déclaration qui
faisait au mois d'octobre dans Sud-Ouest
à propos des blocages des raffineries
par la CGT il est donc l'efficacité d'un
syndicat ne se mesure pas aux
emmerdements qu'il cette époque la
question est en train de savoir si tu
vas à la CGT par exemple est-ce qu'on
partage cette approche du syndicalisme
je dirais que c'est pas évident parce
que on a vu la semaine dernière déjà la
CGT en tout cas pour sa branche pétrole
prévoyez de bloquer à nouveau les
raffineries donc forcément
Philippe Martinez pardon aimerait bien
calmer un peu en tout cas en début de
l'utilisation c'est trop mais c'est pas
évident dans Au mois de mars il va
quitter la tête de la CGT ce qui a
faibli un petit peu ses positions les
autres sont plutôt remontés donc vous
savez entendu parler de cette idée de
des coupures précises sur les élus donc
Philippe Martinez n'a même pas osé
fâcher vraiment contre ces troupes il
leur juste suggéré que peut-être on
pourrait couper le courant ailleurs que
chez les élus on écoute je leur suggère
d'aller voir les belles propriétés il
est beau château des milliardaires ça
serait bien que qu'on coupe qu'on leur
coupe l'électricité pour qu'il se puisse
se mettre dans la peau
quelques jours de des millions de foyers
français qui sont en précarité
énergétique bon est-ce que Laurent
verger est prêt à aller couper le
courant chez Arnaud et chez les autres
pas sûr ce qui est sûr c'est que demain
en tout cas ils seront sans doute en
tête du cortège bras dessus bras dessous
Laurent Berger et Philippe Martinez mais
est-ce que c'est union qui fait leur
force va durer longtemps ça c'est la
question du soir merci beaucoup
Stéphane piquant et concis la promesse
est tenue je vais commencer par les
experts que vous êtes Jean-claude Mahy
et Jean-François Amadieu bon ça va être
massif demain c'est un peu le dire le
million ça c'est l'objectif c'est
l'objectif dans le pays c'est la CGT qui
s'est donné ce chiffre principalement
c'est atteignable
oui je pense que ça t'énerve maintenant
c'est difficile de dire la veille comme
il y aura de monde il y aura du monde
c'est clair
on mesure l'efficacité d'un mouvement à
trois choses en fait et le monde dans
les manifs est-ce que dans le cas
présent parce que il y a les 8 que
c'était Blacko mais il y a aussi les
étudiants et lycéens qui appellent
est-ce qu'il pas parce qu'on appelle que
les gens viennent donc ça fera regarder
qui est dans les cortèges effectivement
et troisième élément qu'il sera le taux
de grève demain pas simplement dans le
public ça on le sait à peu près avant
mais dans le privé on par définition on
le sait pas on le saura que demain moi
les infos que j'ai il y aura des grèves
dans le privé maintenant combien je ne
sais pas donc c'est c'est tous ces
critères qui font qu'un mouvement est
important et dans la durée ça change
beaucoup de choses alors quand on
regarde Jean-François Mathieu les
préavis de grève dans le secteur public
éducation nationale on est à 70% de
grévistes dans l'enseignement
SNCF a ATP quasiment aucun transport il
y a un petit mouvement aussi chez les
contrôleurs aériens est-ce qu'on peut
dire ça part fort d'entrée de jeu oui
peut-être que indicateur le plus
significatif c'est l'éducation nationale
alors attention le chiffre que vous
citez chauffeur il est de source
syndicales mais les remontées
d'informations de l'éducation nationale
du ministère indique des taux de
participation plus élevés que
d'ordinaire et attendu ce qui est quand
même là et c'est très important parce
qu'en effet beaucoup se jouent sur
d'abord l'ensemble des fonctionnaires et
plus précisément l'éducation nationale
non seulement du côté des enseignants
mais aussi et Jean-Claude maillet a
raison de le souligner du côté des
universités et des lycéens ce qui est un
enjeu très important en effet demain et
on verra ce qui se passe ça c'est je
pense ça joue beaucoup sur ce cette
question là pour le reste c'était
attendu RATP SNCF là je dirais que c'est
c'est
pas ça c'est pas vraiment une surprise
de ce côté là pour l'aérien c'est pour
l'instant un peu décevant en revanche
pour l'instant c'est vraiment une
minorité des contrôleurs aériens
Christopher weidberg on sent que le
gouvernement voilà fait bloc et la
majorité aussi il y a eu des réunions de
communicants il faut pas faire de vagues
il faut respecter le droit de grève
franchement vous êtes inquiet vous savez
moi en 1995 j'avais 10 ans et je me
souviens très bien des manifestations
contre les contre les retraites qui
étaient qui avaient duré très longtemps
et avec des bouchons je me sens qu'on
arrive plus à se déplacer et à l'époque
Jacques Chirac il avait été élu sur la
fracture sociale il avait pas de sa
réforme des retraites dans son programme
et donc évidemment il avait pas réussi à
faire passer cette réforme parce qu'il y
avait une mobilisation syndicale
importante en 2010
encore plus de monde dans les rues et
Sarkozy il avait mis dans son programme
la réforme des retraites et donc moi je
suis député j'ai une légitimité
démocratique aujourd'hui on a très
clairement mis dans notre programme
qu'on allait faire cette réforme dans
les termes qui sont définis aujourd'hui
et donc moi je pense que c'est essentiel
qu'on aille au bout de notre réforme on
entend bien les éléments de langage vous
allez quoi trier le bon grain de livret
entre les grévistes demain il y a ceux
qui veulent bloquer le pays comme la CGT
énergie il y a ceux qui exercent un
libre droit comment vous allez faire
pour répondre
l'analyse de ce qui est le bon de du
mauvais enfin le droit le droit de grève
parler des journalistes et a déjà un peu
créé une forme de distinction entre les
deux en fait évidemment quand j'entends
que certains syndicats voudraient couper
l'électricité de certains élus je trouve
que c'est un peu déplorable mais ça je
pense que tout le monde le partage
autour de la table donc je vais pas le
manifester mais au fond j'ai légitimité
démocratique demain c'est le droit de
grève il y aura des syndicats qui sera
qui se rassemblent et puis ensuite il y
a évidemment deux de légitimités
différentes et moi c'est pas en tant que
député que je vais choisir qui sont les
bons les bons avis c'est les mauvaises
gravistes ce qui est pas un quatrième
item par rapport à ce qu'a dit
Jean-Claude Mahy c'est le quatrième item
comment est-ce que l'ensemble de la
population va recevoir la grève et ça
c'est un élément extrêmement important
62 % les Français soutiennent les
chiffres qui disent le soutien de la
grève tant qu'elle n'est pas arrivé le
soutien de la grève il est assez comment
dirais-je mythique ensuite quand on a
les gamins conduire à l'école les choses
qui se passent des coupures
d'électricité etc ça vient ça vient
assez vite la
l'irritation et le l'opinion publique
peut se retourner donc ça c'est
quatrième élément à suivre vous serez
dans les cortèges demain déjà moi je
serai à quand place Saint-Pierre à 10h30
mais l'enjeu c'est en effet la bataille
de l'opinion mais la bataille de
l'opinion c'est déjà de montrer au
gouvernement qui ne l'a pas pris en
compte l'opinion publique parce que là
on a quand même un niveau de
d'opposition à la réforme des retraites
qui est au delà de 80% enfin qui est
entre 75 et 85 % en fonction des
sondages donc c'est quand même une
opposition très importante et
contrairement à ce que disait mon
collègue de la majorité Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas été élu sur un programme de
réforme des retraites il a été élu au
second tour
pour Emmanuel Macron au second tour tout
en disant que je m'opposerai
fondamentalement à sa réforme des
retraites et il y a peut-être 25 ou 207
% des Français qui ont voté pour lui au
premier tour mais au deuxième tour
vraiment ce qui a fait qu'il a été élu
c'était pas la question des retraites
c'était qui il avait en face et pour le
coup je ne pense pas qu'on puisse dire
que la légitimité de la réforme ça soit
celle-là et d'ailleurs il y a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui pour la réforme des
retraites et si en marche n'est pas
majoritaire c'est sans doute enfin
Renaissance aussi parce que les députés
qui portaient ce produit
acquis on peut imaginer on verra
puisqu'il y aura normalement à votre
c'est sûr à l'Assemblée nationale
Christopher weisberg sur la légitimité
de cette argument là je ne le comprends
pas parce qu'en soi et d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est la raison pour laquelle
le quinquennat François Hollande a été
une catastrophe parce que un moment on
est élu sur un programme et si nos
institutions l'élection présidentielle
prime surtout on a des débats qui durent
longtemps et on est au premier tour en
tête et on a eu un débat autour de ces
questions et la réforme des retraites en
faisait partie c'est-à-dire je me
souviens qu'à l'époque on disait que le
programme du président à part la réforme
des retraites on sait pas ce qu'il y
avait on savait pas ce qu'il y avait
dedans donc tout le monde savait à
l'avance c'est vrai et on est en train
de mettre on est en train de
démocratique via les représentants que
vous êtes le problème en 2017 par
exemple c'est que François Hollande est
élu en disant que c'est l'ennemi de la
finance et puis finalement il fait pas
vraiment ce qu'il avait dit dans son
programme et là on se retrouve avec un
quinquennat qui change qui diffère par
rapport à la promesse démocratique donc
moi je crois que on doit être on doit on
doit en tant qu'élu moi encore une fois
j'ai été non pas élu parce que je
m'appelle Christopher ou mais simplement
parce que j'étais le candidat d'une
majorité et par rapport à mes électeurs
et par rapport à mes électeurs je pense
que c'est assez indispensable de
respecter le contrat qu'on a eu avec ces
électeurs et ça c'est quelque chose que
je pense vous devriez vous inspirer
parce que vous la payer un instant ma
campagne mais moi j'ai de campagne
contre la retraite à 64 ans 65 ans pour
ça pour m'y opposer et finalement le
rôle du Parlement c'est aussi de
débattre
il y a la présentation en conseil des
ministres lundi prochain et le débat
normalement si la lieu enfin il aura
lieu mais est-ce qu'il y aura
suffisamment de temps vraiment pour
aller au fond ça commence à au début
février le 6 février d'ailleurs la date
peut faire sourire Jean-Claude Mahy
revenons au syndicat est-ce que cette
unité syndicale est durable vous qui
avez l'expérience la CGT veut déjà elle
le dit déjà avant même la journée de
demain un mouvement reconductible
partout c'est possible Laurent Berger
lui ne s'avance pas non mais parce que
tout simplement il y a une réunion
organisation demain soir voilà donc ils
vont déterminer ensemble ce qu'ils
envisagent pour la suite après vous
pouvez toujours avoir dans une
organisation à CGT par exemple une
fédération qui va aller plus loin qui va
aller plus vite par exemple mais ça
oui moi j'ai jamais été partisan de la
violence ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a
pas de graisse fracturer le front
syndical s'il y a des menaces voire une
base de production d'électricité de
faite
personne mais il y a déjà une baisse de
produits de production d'électricité
j'ai vu ça tout à l'heure donc mais pour
le moment ça touche ça touche personne
mais en tous les cas moi je pense que ce
front syndical va tenir tout simplement
parce que aucune
je comprends bien votre raisonnement et
vous à votre place je le comprends mais
que ce soit le président actuel ou les
présidents précédents ils ont toujours
fait l'erreur selon moi enfin les gens
ne votent pas une présidentielle je dis
bien une présidentielle en apprenant un
catalogue de la Samaritaine voilà et il
est dans un deuxième tour il y en a qui
vote parce qu'ils veulent pas autre
chose voilà c'est plus compliqué donc
après on est obligé de regarder les
regarder les choses c'est pas aussi
simple si simple que ça et et même entre
95 les contextes étaient différents en
95 on était encore sous un de septennat
ce qui change beaucoup les choses ça
veut dire qu'on a un président qui se
consacrait notamment qui surveillait
mais à l'international et qui laissait
faire son premier ministre et d'ailleurs
Jacques Chirac avait dit avec Villepin
qui faisait une connerie on s'attaquant
aux jeunes donc voilà après il a fini
donc ça va tenir ça va tenir parce que
je termine juste moi je crois que le
front syndical va tenir parce que il y
avait des vrais fractures tactiques et
idéologiques entre les différents
syndicats on représente représente
Cherek Thibault et Jean-Claude Mahy et
là il y a une sorte du fait de la
faiblesse extrême des syndicats un
rapprochement idéologique entre les
syndicats on est tout à fait étonné de
voir
un syndicaliste modéré comme Laurent
Berger répéter les mêmes arguments que
que Monsieur Martinez on est tout à fait
étonné de voir par exemple
repositionnement de la de le des
syndicats de cadres qui d'habitude était
justement les syndicats qui étaient dans
le dialogue dans la négociation et ça me
laisse des syndicats qui fait leur
unités je vous propose avant de vous
entendre et vous répondrez parce qu'on
est au cœur de notre débat de les revoir
ces images de 95 et de voir ce qui a
changé pour les grandes centrales entre
graves et disgrâce c'est un décryptage
signé Clément Pérou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était en 1995 ces slogans et ces
images un peu vintage aujourd'hui
résonne encore comme le dernier vrai
moment de gloire des syndicats français
donc c'est clair et bien on va se faire
entendre le plan Juppé tel qu'il est on
n'en veut pas sûr de leur force porté
par l'opinion les organisations
syndicales mobilisent massivement et sur
la durée elles font plier le
gouvernement qui renonce au plan Juppé
sur les retraites de la sécurité sociale
depuis les grandes victoires syndicales
ont presque disparu du paysage la seule
incontestable date de 2006 et du retrait
du CPE le Contrat Première Embauche
voulu par le gouvernement Villepin pour
le reste les syndicats semblent peiner à
s'adapter aux mutations sociales la
tendance est un déclin qui renvoie en
fait à une transformation assez profonde
du monde du travail en fait tout ce qui
faisait la puissance syndicale à
l'époque de ce qu'on a coutume d'app les
Trente Glorieuses à savoir des grands
des grands établissements industriels
des collectivités ouvrières assez fortes
assez soudées à mesure que le chômage de
masse se développe que l'emploi est
précarisé externalisé sous-traiter il y
a tout un tas de support de la puissance
syndicale qui ont été fragilisés ce ne
sont pas les syndicats qui gouvernent
c'est le gouvernement ce ne sont pas les
syndicats qui font la loi c'est le
Parlement régulièrement pointé du doigt
par les responsables politiques débordés
par de nouvelles formes de contestation
les syndicats ne semblent plus au centre
du jeu avant le passage par une
organisation syndicale était un peu un
passage obligé pour construire un
mouvement social ça reste aujourd'hui
mais par exemple l'existence des réseaux
sociaux des smartphones etc facilitent
la communication entre les notamment les
salariés quand il s'agit de se mobiliser
on l'a vu avec le l'histoire du
collectif des contrôleurs en décembre
dernier concurrencé affaibli les grandes
centrales syndicales veulent montrer
demain
peuvent encore mobiliser lors des grands
rendez-vous
Jean-Claude Mahy ce sont plus les
dirigeants des grandes entrailles qui
contrôlent leur base non
on peut toujours dire ça mais moi j'y
crois pas une seconde alors qu'il y ait
des difficultés pour le syndicalisme en
France ou ailleurs d'ailleurs ça y est
les périodes où les difficultés
économiques sont importantes tous
sociales ou autre c'est jamais des
périodes où vous faites de l'adhésion
par exemple vous faites plus de
l'adhésion quand le syndicat décroche
quelque chose et c'est au niveau des
entreprises d'administrations que ça
c'est valable en France c'est valable
dans d'autres pays moi je pense pas que
la difficulté
s'il se retrouve aujourd'hui enfin on a
un problème dans notre pays et qui s'est
aggravé sous la présidence actuelle ce
problème c'est quoi c'est un problème de
méthode on peut on peut discuter du fond
c'est quoi le problème de méthode c'est
qu'en fait dans le privé on négocie on
négocier que le CNP enfin Medef
aujourd'hui on est on négocie à la fin
on essaie de se mettre d'accord on signe
un contrat et ça engage les deux parties
ça veut dire qu'on fait un compromis
depuis en France il y a pas cette
tradition quand on discute avec les
pouvoirs publics c'est une concertation
concertation il y a deux façons de la
faire
en gros vous allez au fond du dossier
c'est une négociation sans signature
mais vous avez discuté à fond du dossier
ou alors vous vous les recevez mettre 10
fois 15 fois et vous voulez consulter et
vous n'en tenez pas compte la
consultation et pas de la concertation
c'est fortement aggravé parce que le
pouvoir ne doit pas être surpris tous
les syndicats depuis le début disent que
sur l'âge ils sont pas d'accord donc
c'est pour ça que le front va tenir
alors on est effectivement maintenant
vous savez c'est comme ça
un bras de fer par définition il y en a
un qui gagne qui en a qui permet
hypothèse la loi est votée et ça passe
je sais pas ce que je souhaite à titre
personnel mais ça passe vous pouvez
regarder l'histoire vous pouvez regarder
95 vous pouvez regarder 2016 etc le
politique qui gagne a toujours un effet
boomerang fort et le fait boomerang
souvent il est
politiquement
c'est les élections
on risque aujourd'hui il est là oui le
risque aujourd'hui il est là et ça je
dis on joue pas moi je dis arrêtons de
jouer avec le feu on ne joue pas avec la
démocratie vaut mieux préférer dans la
méthode le réformisme ça veut dire la
vraie discussion que l'autoritarisme
allez Christopher viceberg vous répond
sur la méthode c'est vrai qu'on a le
sentiment que elle les a entendu mais
pas écouté c'est syndicats c'est ce
qu'ils disent tous en tous les cas ça
c'est une consultation pas une
concertation je suis pas un spécialiste
du syndicative je souscrit ce que vous
dites c'est-à-dire qu'en France il y a
toujours ce côté on a l'impression qu'il
y a une concertation et qu'à la fin la
concertation elle a pas servi à grand
chose mais sur le sur ce que vous dites
sur l'argument du RN moi j'ai du mal
avec cette argument encore une fois je
reviens en 2017 on est élu sur un
programme aussi de réforme des retraites
ce que je regrette c'est que encore une
fois en Allemagne ils sont en train de
monter les retraits jusqu'à 67 ans et
encore une fois en général
juste là-dessus les comparaisons
internationales faut faire attention
parce que nous on a aussi taux plein à
67 ans donc vous pouvez aussi en
Allemagne partir avant avec une durée de
cotisation plus faible on peut pas
uniquement
il y a du grain à moudre encore est-ce
que il y a du leste que vous pouvez
lâcher sur le fond on parle beaucoup des
carrières longues les 44 ans cotisations
des débats assemblés avec des milliers
d'amendements donc j'imagine bien qu'il
va y avoir une négociation avec aussi
évidemment avec les oppositions et avec
le Sénat donc il va se passer des choses
enfin c'est évident mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui que je vais vous dire ce que
ce que va être le résultat
rouge vous souhaitez qu'il évolue encore
ce texte dans le débat parlementaire
forcément sinon c'est comme si je vous
disais que je voulais pas être
parlementaire
que très vite le débat je pense qu'il
faut impossible il va y avoir un débat
on a quand même réussi depuis le début à
faire des avoir des textes qui sont
souvent adoptés il y a pas eu de 49-3
sur un certain nombre de tech enfin il y
a aussi pas mal de textes qui sont
adoptés dans ce cadre là donc
le climat social parce que vous avez
entendu ce collègue peut-être sociologue
du travail
compliqué que maintenant les syndicats
sont débordés et qu'il y a d'autres
mouvements il y a cette note aussi des
renseignements généraux qui n'a pas pu
vous échapper qui explique qu'il y a des
mouvements autonomes ça peut être les
artisans boulangers ça peut être une
résurgence des gilets jaunes avec les
réseaux sociaux tout ça c'est dangereux
c'est sérieux ou pas
le mouvement syndical on parle de des
divisions est-ce que il y aura une unité
ou pas bon ça a toujours été comme ça
dans le mouvement syndical situation
c'est détériorer il y a de plus en plus
organisations syndicales au fur et à
mesure qu'il y avait de moins en moins
d'adhérents bon c'est une exception au
plan international c'est comme ça mais
si vous voulez après sur l'unité
syndicale on peut être peut-être un peu
moins optimiste car si l'unité dure
si l'unité dure comme elle est
actuellement au niveau national pour
demain si elle dure si on la constate
dans les différents secteurs d'activité
ce sera une exception vraiment
extraordinaire dans l'histoire du
mouvement syndical français il faut
quand même le savoir parce que même en
dans tous les autres moments vous pouvez
regarder il y avait toujours ici ou là
il y avait pas tout le monde bon il y
avait pas tout le monde il y avait
toujours une fois l'une ça l'autre fois
est faux une autre fois la CFDT etc à
différents endroits ou même au niveau
national qui n'est tout le monde n'était
pas ensemble donc ça c'est le premier
point sur le mouvement autonome qui
déborde français par comparaison c'est
que ça n'a jamais comment dire c'est un
mouvement syndical qui a obtenu des
résultats via le conflit souvent qui est
très institutionnalisé mais qui a
toujours été faible
dans son ancrage dans son onde
d'adhérents dans son voilà qui a été
affaibli par les réformes récentes aussi
par ses moyens de fonctionnement mais
donc si vous voulez le fait qu'il y ait
il y avait déjà des coordinations Sud
est apparu à la suite de coordination
dans les années 80 et au fond les
organisations syndicales françaises à la
différence de ce qu'on observe dans tous
les autres pays quasiment sauf peut-être
en Italie dans deux trois pays ce sont
des organisations qui ne contrôlent pas
en réalité qui n'ont pas une maîtrise
comme on pourrait se l'imaginer des
salariés pas pas autant que les gens se
l'imaginent et c'est logique ces
organisations sont nombreuses on peut le
déplorer parce que pour avoir moins de
conflits et mieux gérer le dialogue
social il faut des syndicats qui
devraient être normalement moins
nombreux
syndical et donc en fait être débordé
par les réseaux sociaux ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui les boulangers
mobilisés et agissons sous forme de
collectif quoi désormais
croissance c'est vrai que les réseaux
sociaux ont accéléré je dirais que ça
rajoute une couche supplémentaire il y
en a une autre qu'il faut pas oublier
parce que demain c'est ce que les
renseignements généraux indiquent aussi
et c'est le problème nouveau qu'on va
avoir par rapport à l'histoire du
mouvement syndical quand même c'est ce
qui va se passer dans la rue et là
depuis 2016 la situation c'est sacrément
dégradée elles sont paroxysme pendant
les gilets jaunes
bien sûr et pas juste les Black Blocs
maintenant
publique peut-être Roselyne Bachelot
juste un bémol par rapport à ce que vous
dites ce qu'on observe d'ordinaire dans
les sondages d'opinion sur le soutien et
la sympathie à l'égard des mouvements
c'est que dans un premier temps on peut
s'attendre à une augmentation c'est ce
qu'on voit d'ailleurs depuis ces
derniers jours et encore hier de la
popularité il est vrai que lorsqu'il y
aura les premiers rapages dans les
manifestations dans les premiers
blocages voilà c'est ça là que les gens
seront emmerdés comme on dit dans là
effectivement on va voir que d'abord
chez les personnes âgées électorales
plus conservateurs il va y avoir une
petite baisse mais le résultat n'est pas
forcément favorable et exécutif car tous
les sondages nous ont montré que
traditionnellement ce que les gens vont
dire il faut que ça cesse mais qui en
est responsable l'exécution par
conséquent il faut qu'il arrête et c'est
à Lui d'arrêter tout ça en s'aidant et
ça c'est classique c'est l'effet un peu
paradoxal
c'est que le gouvernement a une
responsabilité immense que ce soit à la
fois
dans la manière dont les syndicats ont
été traités depuis 5 ans maintenant il y
a une forme d'anticorporatisme qui s'est
retrouvé dans le discours d'Emmanuel
Macron de sa première campagne mais
aussi de la campagne de 2022 de refus de
discuter avec les syndicats on l'a
observé sur l'assurance chômage ou tous
les syndicats étaient contre et rien n'a
été fait pour aller donner ne serait-ce
un petit bout de mesures et un petit
bout de dialogue avec les syndicats et
là sur les retraites et Jean-Claude
maillots
intermédiaires en général le passage 64
ans je ne bougerai pas Elizabeth borne
et se comporte avec les syndicats comme
avec les députés vous pouvez faire ce
que vous voulez mais moi ça sera 64 ans
ou rien maintenant qu'on a fixé un
plancher et là on est on est un
gouvernement qui est borné et et ça tout
le monde tout le monde le ressent et les
Françaises et les Français en famille
est-ce que le président aime ou aime pas
les syndicats
c'est pas le terme mais d'aimer qui
convient est-ce qu'il les considèrent je
après il a pas la fin il y a pas une
c'est pas le seul hein mais il a pas la
culture du dialogue social c'est pas
c'est pas son histoire c'est pas son
truc bon et lui a toujours considéré que
la place il le disait en plus que la
place est syndicace c'est dans
l'entreprise tout ce qui est national ça
relève de l'intérêt général et les
syndicats n'ont rien à y faire voilà les
années Jospin la CFDT c'est pas la même
culture non la première oui je le
connais peu Isabelle
par exemple sur la première période de
du président actuel 2017 si les choses
s'y a pu y avoir une concertation je le
dis clairement c'est parce qu'il y avait
une ministre du Travail à l'époque qui
était attaché à la concertation et qui a
fait la Pénicaud et qui a fait la
concertation vous voyez c'était c'était
lié à ça c'était pas lié à la vaut une
volonté présidentielle en tout cas
aujourd'hui le gouvernement est très
attentif voire un peu voilà sur les
charbons il y a 4 ministres qui peuvent
parler seulement ce reste vous êtes prié
d'attendre Olivier du soft pour le
travail Bruno Le Maire pour l'économie
Clément bon des transports et le
porte-parole Olivier Véran tout est
extrêmement verrouillé on a vraiment
l'impression que le moindre dérapage
voilà ça c'est normal vous connaissez ce
genre de communication
qui parle et une seule parce que sinon
c'est le merdier
à quoi vous serez attentif demain avant
tout le nombre de personnes du privé
dans la rue qu'est-ce que vous avez
regardé les sondages dans le détail
évidemment on va être attentif à ce qui
se passe on va respecter le droit de
grève on va voir quels sont les
réactions dans le privé dans le public
moi je suis assez d'accord avec ce que
vous dites sur au fond je pense que les
succès du syndicalisme notamment en
Allemagne c'est d'être capable de
négocier notamment au sein de
l'entreprise notamment au sein des
salaires c'est cette capacité là et en
France
il y a moins d'efficacité et évidemment
Emmanuel Macron il a connu ses années ou
des syndicats finalement se sont
retrouvés de moins en moins légitimes et
il a choisi sur le nom sur les de faire
des réformes qui sont des réformes
nationales et d'assumer ces choix
politiques
j'aimerais bien que vous nous disiez un
peu quelles sont vos capteurs on a
beaucoup dit que les marcheurs étaient
hors-sol un peu déconnecté il y a une
grande réunion de groupe hier à
l'Assemblée où tout le monde un peu à
faire monter les les commentaires des
Français en circonscription voilà ils
ont envie d'en découdre ou pas les
Français selon vous
les réunions de groupe ça a toujours
servi à faire volonté les terrains il y
a toujours une et il y a toujours eu des
gens qui comptent aussi
on est tous très mobilisés on est tous
très mobilisés et on sait tous pour
quand on est là parce qu'on a été élu
sur une réforme
Maik est très important il faut rappeler
que de beaucoup de ce qui se passe tiens
au fait que autant dans les entreprises
en effet il y a beaucoup de négociations
on sait faire autant il y a un problème
avec le politique c'est le fait que il
empiète sur évidemment les prorogatives
des partenaires sociaux moi même j'avais
élaboré une proposition de révision
constitutionnelle il y a plusieurs
années pour aller plus loin que la loi
l'archer parce que le code du travail
mais c'est la question
ça n'a pas eu de une grande destinée
mais c'est assez simple c'est comme on
trouve au niveau européen en effet
lorsqu'il s'agit du politique au motif
qui lui aurait une légitimité électorale
et bien au fond on se dispense de
processus de négociation on ne confie
pas aux partenaires le soir négocié on
organise pas des négociations
il y a quelque chose à améliorer dans la
pratique de négociation à l'instar de ce
qu'on fait en Europe du jeu avec
d'autres pour les élus de la nation
le temps qui nous est imparti s'achève
mais en tout cas voilà la main la main
est tendue vous restez avec moi Roselyne
Bachelot merci pour ce débat rendez-vous
demain soir sur ce plateau pour tirer
les premiers enseignements de de cette
grande journée de de mobilisation dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties
prises de nos affranchis vous les voyez
fin prêt en coulisses j'aurais mis
Baudot pour la politique Fanny guynochet
pour l'économie et Stéphanie Despierres
pour le bourbon Express je disais ce
soir des frondeurs en macronie mais
d'abord le bal des hypocrites Rosine
Bachelot qui cartonne en librairie
techno élu artiste vous n’épargnez
personne dans ces 682 jours c'est publié
chez plomb et puisque nous sommes à
l'Assemblée on a regardé attentivement
ce que vous pensiez de nos députés
l'invitation est signée ce soir par
Maïté Frémont regardez
si on vous invite Roselyne Bachelot
c'est pour nous parler de votre nouveau
livre
692 jours le bal des hypocrites un
flashback de vos deux années comme
ministre de la Culture en pleine
épidémie de coronavirus une mission
dites-vous commando alors que les lieux
de culture ne réouvre pas jugé non
essentiels je plaide coupable
sur ce mot que je n'ai pas prononcé
moi-même et sur lesquels j'ai voulu
m'expliquer mais aussi de demander qu'on
reconnaisse que nous avons fait ce qu'il
devait être fait nous voilà replonger
était 2020 avec votre audition à
l'Assemblée nationale en tant qu’on
sienne ministre de la Santé pour parler
covid mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
pays infantilisé il faut quand même un
peu se prendre en main dans ce pays la
Commission est largement reprise par la
presse deux jours plus tard Jean Castex
Premier ministre vous demande d'entrer
au gouvernement pour sauver la culture
il faut tenir tête au président Castex
avait mieux que personne qu'il fallait
confier les clés de Valois à une vieille
tête blanchie sous le harnais des
emmerdements en l'occurrence Bachelot
bien malheureux celui qui tente de vous
classer aujourd'hui chroniqueuse télé
vous avez été plusieurs fois ministre
sous Jacques Chirac Nicolas Sarkozy ou
encore Emmanuel Macron vous êtes connu
pour votre franc-parler et votre votre
liberté de penser une réputation des vos
premiers pas à l'Assemblée les voici aux
côtés de votre père c'était en 1988
député vous l'avez été pendant 14 ans et
les us et coutume du Palais Bourbon
n'ont plus beaucoup de secret pour vous
alors en reprenant du service pour les
toutes premières questions gouvernement
en tant que ministre de la Culture vous
êtes sur vos gardes si vous vacillez
bafouillez ignorer la meute ne vous
lâchera plus et comme dans la basse-cour
la volaille à terre sera piquée jusqu'à
la mort durant ces deux ans vous y
retenez un désintérêt profondémentaires
pour la culture en particulier par ceux
qui accusaient de ne pas la considérer
comme essentiel dans ce livre vous
dénoncez un bal des hypocrites dans le
cinéma notamment mais aussi sur
l'échiquier politique les députés de la
majorité et lui en 2017 en prennent pour
leur grade tout comme vos anciens
compagnons de lutte à droite le choc
Furude en 1988 j'avais devant moi
Jacques Chirac Edouard Balladur celui
octobre ce n'était même pas en Ligue 2
mais Nationale 3 avec Christian Jacob en
président du parti et Damien Abad en
président de groupe misère après avoir
Lucé 270 pages à la sulfateuse une
question madame la ministre n'avez-vous
pas peur du retour de bateau
réponse Roselyne Bachelot non seulement
je n'en ai pas peur mais je dirais que
j'ai pas voulu faire un livre à l'eau
sucrée à l'eau tiède je suis une
lanceuse d'alerte et finalement les
diagnostics que je pose sont partagées
par ceux qui analysent finement finement
la politique la déperdition dans ma
famille politique la déperdition des
valeurs des personnalités cette sorte de
perte de substance elle est aussi un
appel un appel à ressaisis
on vous sent quand même un peu blessés
parce que vous en avez pris plein la
gueule il faut le dire pendant cette
période du covid runevalois et vous
vouliez aussi quelque part rendre
justice prendre une forme de revanche
avec ce livre non le terme de revanche
n'est pas n'est pas adapté mais c'est
pas un livre pleurnichard pas du tout
des choses fortes parce que
je me suis battu comme un
comme un vrai guerrier pour sauver la
culture de ce pays maintenant que la
crise est terminée espérons que ça dure
tout le monde a reconnu que la France et
le pays qui a le plus aidé ces artistes
et structures 15 milliards c'est
absolument incroyable il suffit d'aller
voir des artistes étrangers en Europe
pour ils disent mais la France c'est le
pays Cocagne comme a dit Mary Nicole
Lemieux là la cantatrice québécoise
des hypocrisies des attaques publiques
et des remerciements en coulisses
d'ailleurs ça c'est typiquement français
ou c'est la nature humaine oui c'est un
peu quand même une culture française on
a l'impression qu'on perd sa liberté si
on dit au gouvernement bah écoutez c'est
chouette vous m'avez vous nous avez aidé
etc et on s'oblige en quelque sorte il y
a une sorte de police de la pensée qui
oblige à attaquer le gouvernement même
si ensuite quand on est face la mini
sont dit bah écoutez merci vous nous
avez sauvé alors vous n'êtes pas tendre
avec le nouveau monde et
particulièrement les députés en marche
qui arrivent en 2017 gonflée à bloc
péremptoire n'est que des gens
totalement le terrain pour ses bisous je
vous cite biberonnés au 35 heures et au
5 semaines de congés payés d'un boulot
salarié les contraintes de la vie
parlementaire étaient absurdes ils
étaient à ce point-là hors sol mais
c'est à dire que on le on leur a dit de
faire ça
c'était le nouveau c'était le nouveau
monde contre l'ancien moi j'ai regardé
j'ai regardé
quand des mères de ma circonscription ou
vous demandez partement me racontait
qu'il n'avait pas le téléphone de leur
député qu'il y avait pas de permanence
que quand on invitait à remettre un
trophée sur un jeu de boules ou assister
au bal des pompiers ou banquet des
anciens combattants on disait non j'ai
droit mon dimanche mais d'un autre côté
ces députés il faut s'y refléter quelque
chose quelque chose de un vrai courant
qui existe dans tous les dans tous les
secteurs dans toutes les professions
regardez les débats qui en ce moment sur
la valeur travail
l'idée de consacrer comme je l'ai fait
toute ma vie
85 ou 90 heures à ma fonction
parlementaire il y a toutes sortes de
jeunes députés qui pour qui à qui ça ne
parle pas donc
un élément spécifique d'un mouvement
politique ce serait ce serait de la
faute au nom cumul des mandats et là
vous faites votre mea culpa vous avez dû
endosser un mot qui n'est pas le vôtre
on en parlait dans le sujet ce mot c'est
le mot de non-essentiel au moment de la
fermeture des lieux de culture pendant
le covid Grand Corps Malade on vous
citez intégralement la chanson voilà on
a fait le titre de son de son spectacle
à l'Olympia qui a pu mettre ce mot dans
la bouche d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
ce sont des techno que vous fustigez
aussi dans le livre
en fait c'est un mot qui définit des
commerces de subsistance
les commerces essentiels et je cite
toujours cette comparaison on mange tous
les jours mais on va pas au théâtre tous
les jours est-ce que ça veut dire pour
autant que la le théâtre n'est pas aussi
essentiel que le pain qu'on mange
évidemment moi qui est une cultureuse le
mot avec tous les guillemets du monde
pense que la culture c'est ce qui
construit un individu et au-delà de
l'individus qui construit une
collectivité nationale et un rayonnement
d'ailleurs de son pays et ce mot
discours présidentiel ce monstre fait
que on en arrive à écrire ça et on se
rend pas compte que ça va créer une
déflagration dans le milieu de la
culture ce mot serait sans doute posté
inaperçu dans d'autres circonstances
parce que tout le monde l'aurait compris
mais vous savez quand on verse un peu de
sel sur une plaie à vif ça réagit parce
que le évidemment le monde de la culture
était blessé mais néanmoins moi ce que
je constate actuellement
c'est que la crise est terminée et je
trouve la culture
tu es terriblement absente du débat du
débat national comme si
regardez ce qui s'est passé je disais un
excellent journal économique qui
s'appelle Les Échos et un papier indiqué
qu'on avait demandé aux Français si vous
aviez une cagnotte de plusieurs dizaines
de milliards vous étiez au gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous en feriez de cette
cagnotte alors on parle du des
entraînements du pays on parle des
retraites on parle de la santé on parle
de l'éducation qui sont des sujets
extrêmement importants et on ne parle
pas de culture et
la culture au moins ça a été le petit
avantage de cette crise épouvantable qui
a traversé le milieu culturel
et de ceux qui sont en gestion d'une
partie de ce milieu qui dure c'est qu'on
au moins on a parlé de culture alors
vous en voulez à certains artistes à
succès il y a eu beaucoup de papiers
mais vous c'est rare de les citer alors
vous vous citez Clara Luciani vous citez
Benjamin Biolay qui ont joué des un peu
les victimes sacrifiées alors que il ne
manquait de rien vous êtes assez dur
aussi avec le les gens du cinéma gavé
d'argent et d'aide plus tard dans le
livre qui conchit l'État à la télévision
et vous dites cette phrase ces gens de
gauche géo avec l'accent circonflexe sur
le haut méprise le peuple qui pour eux a
des goûts de merde elle est violente
cette phrase mais elle dit des choses
aussi c'est à dire que là effectivement
moi je n'ai pas attaqué la première il y
a eu des mots très désagréables qui ont
été dites à mon endroit
et je suis resté je me suis trouvé d'un
calme olympien quelques fois justement
parce que je comprenais la souffrance je
comprenais la douleur mais j'ai le droit
aussi à la suite de ça de dire que j'ai
trouvé ça
a été
j'ai trouvé ça juste et je le dis alors
par contre effectivement à l'occasion de
la cérémonie des Césars
j'ai pas été la seule c'est un classefiq
c'est vraiment un classique de la
cérémonie des Césars on conchit le
ministre de la Culture et là surtout
s'il est droite alors évidemment
et il est la tassé dans ce fauteuil
comme le boxeur au coin du ring
je demande pas qu'on arrive comme les
bluebel girls enlevant la jambe et en
disant Roselyne Bachelot est formidable
mais étant donné que on a grâce à une
politique d'État partagée par la droite
et par la gauche on n'a pas été les les
innovateurs de cette politique qui date
de 1946 avec le Centre national du
cinéma et de l'image animée mais au
moins on pourrait dire voilà s'il y a
encore en Europe une seule industrie
cinématographique une seule c'est grâce
à l'état bon on pourrait passer on
pourrait ne pas se faire cracher à la
figure c'est
c'est un petit manuel de combat pour un
ministre novice qui pourrait tomber dans
tous les pièges mais c'est aussi un
regard sur la culture à la fois sur le
ministère et sur les politiques il y a
un chiffre moi qui m'a énormément frappé
80% de l'aide du ministère de la Culture
et réservé à Paris et à l'Île-de-France
80%, ça veut dire que tout est construit
à Paris ou en Île-de-France est-ce que
c'est pas la faute d'un certain Jack
Lang non c'est la construction de la
France
Michel vinogue dit très justement en
France l'État a précédé la nation alors
qu'en général dans les pays la nation
précède l'État et tout ce qui est de
l'ancien régime ou du nouveau régime a
été fait pour asseoir le pouvoir
exécutif c'est aussi bien le château de
Versailles pour mettre les vassaux à les
mettre à Kia et
les politiques ont été des politiques
qui ne sont pas des politiques
décentralisées la généralisation c'est
très nouveau dans notre pays mais toutes
les grandes machines culturelles se sont
construites dans un État centralisé et
maintenant on fait pour changer ça il
faut que le mouvement proposer tout en
canardant mais comment on fait pour
avancer c'est-à-dire il faut arriver à
d'abord prendre des décisions moi j'ai
proposé qui est aucune nouvelle
structure qui ne soit financée par
l'État dans les 20 ans à venir qui soit
financé dans la région parisienne de
faire un effort considère évidemment
entretenir ce qu'il y a et de développer
des politiques alors je suis contre une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
parce que sinon réduire le ministère de
la Culture à une sorte d'agence de
conseil et d'expertise sera mon avis une
erreur mais développer des politiques de
partenariat et développer de grandes
actions moi d'ailleurs je rends hommage
à Emmanuel Macron parce que les
présidents de la République ont tous
fait un grand un grand machin
mais tout à fait emblématique mais il
est pas au Quai Branly il est pas au
musée d'Orsay ce sont pas les grands
travaux c'est pas le Centre Pompidou il
fait le Centre de la francophonie et de
la langue française il le fait à
Villers-Cotterêts dans la région des
Hauts de France la région la plus
déshérité de la métropole et dans la
partie la plus déshérité de cette région
il y a un vrai changement de paradigme
et vous en parlez d'ailleurs vous
racontez votre rencontre la première
fois que vous rencontrez Emmanuel Macron
682 jours le bal des hypocrites
c'est-à-dire chez plomb vous restez avec
moi Rosine bachelon c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris leur carte blanche tout de
suite
soit les affranchis installez-vous Fanny
Guy nochet pour l'économie qui va nous
parler de cet appel des millionnaires à
Davos ça n'a pas pu vous échapper
forcément Fanny et puis un autre regard
sur les retraites on nous parlez
Rousseaux contrat social tout à l'heure
j'aurais mis Baudot nos deux affranchis
made in france Info mais on commence
avec le bourbon Express comme chaque
soir l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nous est racontée ce soir par Stéphanie
Despierres bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir
alors ce soir je vous raconte l'histoire
des premiers frondeurs qui cassent
l'ambiance dans le camp présidentiel le
mot d'ordre chez les macronistes c'est
serré les rangs face à l'opinion et au
syndicats et patatras et bien lundi soir
la députée et ancienne ministre
d'Emmanuel Macron barbara Pompili glisse
à des confrères hors caméra qu'à ce
stade elle ne vote pas la réforme des
retraites depuis elle disparaît et ce
qui va et micro et caméra hier on la
croise aux quatre colonnes pas un mot
cet après-midi même chose avant vous le
voyez de revenir et d'assumer c'est très
clair pour l'instant c'est donc à la
réforme des retraites
je suis une députée qui fait son travail
qui a toujours été loyal vis-à-vis de la
majorité parce qu'elle veut que cette
majorité réussisse mais qui a des idées
à porter et qui considèrent que la
réforme des retraites telles qu'elle est
aujourd'hui mais mérite d'être plus
juste et donc d'être retravaillé voilà
est-ce que vous seriez capable de voter
contre si jamais le résultat la copie
finale ne vous convient pas jusqu'à
capable de tout mais moi le travail que
je fais c'est un travail pour pouvoir
voter pour cette réforme évidemment
un FAF fronde en Macron et alors trois
autres députés céciliak Mireille laposte
et là Dupont envisage elle aussi de ne
pas voter alors elles appartiennent
toutes à en commun le mouvement
politique vous le voyez sur cette photo
de Barbara à Pompili alors si elle
disent le disent tout haut c'est car
elles espèrent encore influencer le
gouvernement le texte définitif de la
loi ne sera présenté que lundi en
conseil des ministres elle refuse les 44
ans de cotisations pour les carrières
longues elles veulent des mesures
supplémentaires pour les seniors pour
les femmes et c'est le moment où jamais
pour elle de le dire elle le savent
après ce peut-être trop tard car face à
une opposition très remontée dans
l'hémicycle les députés macronistes
devront à faire bloc la textes sera très
peu touché un autre député un cinquième
donc fait la même analyse et faire
entendre sa voix à dissonance écouter
dans l'état je trouve que je ne pourrai
pas la voter dans cet état-là je voterai
pas quand mais je ne la voterai pas
parce que j'estime que nous ne prenons
pas en compte la pénibilité nous prenons
pas en compte si vous voulez le travail
des seniors il faut quoi dans le
gouvernement que des godillots qui
appuient sur un bouton ou des gens qui
fassent remonter on cinq affronter sur
170 députés Renaissance c'est
franchement pas beaucoup pour l'instant
oui c'est une poignée c'est sûr mais à
la veille de la grande mobilisation
syndicale ça tombe quand même assez mal
pour la présidentielle c'est un très
mauvais signal c'est trop
fort pour l'instant ils ne sont que 5 un
député me disait c'est quand même un
très mauvais signal c'est très
désagréable c'est déloyal mais
officiellement il n'y a pas de quoi qui
était la présidente du groupe
Robert G c'est assez mal parti ça te
réforme des retraites vous avez déjà vos
frondeurs on a surtout une majorité qui
est très déterminée parce que cette
réforme elle est nécessaire absolue il y
a pas un député Renaissance qui ne s'est
pas engagé sur un projet qui était un
projet législatif et présidentiel qui
prévoyait le report de l'âge légal on ne
sait tous engagés sur ce projet-là ce
qu'il faut garantir c'est que ce soit le
plus juste possible notamment pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt c'est
ce qu'on fait sur les carrières longues
les carrières très longues et je le dis
très clairement il y aura pas une voix
du groupe Renaissance qui manquera au
moment du vote sur la réforme des
retraites alors quel est le sort réservé
à tous ceux qui voteraient contre ils
sortent ils sortent ils sont exclus pas
si vite nous dit-on voilà ce que nous
ont répondu sur les députés renaissances
interrogés
est-ce qu'il faut exclure les députés
Renaissance qui annoncent que là pour
l'instant en l'état une votent pas la
réforme
position ensuite il y a le texte d'abord
dire qu'on va pas voter contre un texte
qu'on n'a pas entre les mains c'est
particulier puisque le texte n'a pas
encore été déposé en conseil des
ministres donc on sait pas exactement ce
qui contient donc attendant le texte
présentons des amendements discutons ici
à l'Assemblée puis on verra ensuite il y
aura un débat sur la réforme du retraite
ils ont pas dit qu'il voteraient pas ils
ont dit que ils attendent leur convient
pas en l'état mais le texte il a
vocation à être amélioré et à être
enrichie de leur proposition donc il est
pas question d'exclure et les questions
d'inclure
inclure oui parce qu'avec une majorité
relative désormais chaque voix compte
pour Emmanuel Macron s'il veut faire
passer sa réforme des retraites alors il
ne faut pas insulter l'avenir surtout ne
braquer aucun député de son groupe et
tenter jusqu'au bout de tous les ramener
à bord du navire macroniste Roselyne
comment vous regardez ça je suis
toujours étonnée des consignes de
groupes qui me paraissent
anticonstitutionnel et j'ai participer à
un groupe ou la liberté de vote était
inscrite dans les textes fondateurs
tout mandat impératif et nul on n'a pas
à donner des consignes de vote au député
mais ce qu'il faut voir quand même
première fissure dans ce groupe où il
faut rien exagérer il faut voir
effectivement
j'ai connu pire
qu'une vieille bête bon on verra ça en
tout cas dans dans les jours dans les
jours à venir on continue à parler
retraite avec vous Jean-Rémy il y a
selon vous un échec dans cette réforme
ou dans la manière dont tu as des
présenter celui d'arriver à proposer un
constat social renouvelé dans notre
société il est où notre contrat social
alors vous parlez de Jean-Jacques
Rousseau tout à l'heure c'est vrai ce
qui fait qu'un peuple est un peuple que
chaque individu s'inscrit dans un projet
et dans le même projet je suis frappé
par la manière dont notre société ne
parvient pas ou peut-être ne parvient
plus à s'accorder sur un sujet on parle
des retraites du nucléaire de l'écologie
ce sont des grands débats qui sont
structurants censés s'inscrire dans un
projet plus large mais personne ne
semble vouloir prendre ces sujets dans
leur globalité ensemble condamner à
aborder chaque sujet de manière un peu
sectorielle microéconomique
micropolitique illustration selon moi du
rétrécissement de nos regards sur nos
sphères personnelles c'est-à-dire
pendant le covidence c'est un peu tous
demandés ce que ce qu'elle allait
devenir notre société si cette épidémie
allait changer
quelque chose on était tous confrontés
au même risque au même contraintes le
monde d'après allait-il être plus
solidaire je pense qu'on a déjà la
réponse c'est l'individualisme qui monte
en flèche individualisme repli sur sa
sphère de proximité la solidarité elle
s'exprime toujours évidemment mais sur
les gens autour de nous sur ceux qui
nous ressemblent pour les autres bah
tant pis pour certains c'est même un
projet politique regarder l'extrême
droite le National l'identité le reste
non et sans surprise le RN a le vent en
poupe mais pour en revenir en retraite
on exalte notre modèle la répartition
l'idée que tout le monde y participe
mais qui s'engage réellement sur ce
projet collectif du gouvernement et bien
oui et non aujourd'hui l'argument il est
mis sur l'équilibre financier c'est un
projet ça l'équilibre financier est-ce
que ce que vous ça vous excite de
d'équilibrer vos comptes franchement à
part l'Amicale à des experts-comptables
et peut-être Édouard Philippe personne
ne se lève le matin booster par
l'énergie d'équilibrer ses comptes le
gouvernement il a aussi fait l'erreur au
début souvenez-vous de laisser entendre
que cette réforme elle financerait
d'autres choses ça ce n'est pas du tout
l'esprit de une autre modèle de retraite
et puis cette critique elle vaut aussi
pour l'opposition tous ceux qui laissent
penser qu'il suffira de taxer quelques
patrimoines de milliardaires la belle
affaire t'accélériche est-ce que ça
c'est un projet de société dans un
instant avec avec Fanny est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer plusieurs modèles oui
puisque le débat politique ce sont
plusieurs projets de société parfois
concurrents plus ou moins réaliste mais
c'est évidemment ça de débattre le
problème c'est qu'on peine à trouver un
peu notre équilibre chacun à sa chapelle
mais quelle est la vision collective et
surtout qui se donne les moyens
d'embarquer tout le monde ça m'inspire
de questions est-ce que cette difficulté
à présenter un nouveau contrat social
renouvelé est-ce que c'est un manque
d'ambition ou peut-être de talent de
notre classe politique ou est-ce que
c'est une difficulté collective
aujourd'hui à anticiper un nouveau
modèle en fait dont on n'a pas encore
tout à fait les clés un monde redéfini
avec de nouvelles limites notamment les
limites écologiques cette deuxième
hypothèse aurait peut-être le mérite de
laisser un peu plus d'espoir justement
on est sur un projet que présenté comme
uniquement financier libre des comptes
qui pourraient ne pas embarquer des gens
et pourquoi me dit-on pas en fait ne le
présentons pas d'une autre façon parce
que quand Mermet interroge les Français
dans Francoscopie la seule chose pour
lesquelles les Français sont capables de
se mobiliser c'est leurs enfants ils ne
croient plus en la liberté en la nation
en la France a déjà bon leurs enfants et
de dire quand même parce que c'est ça la
vérité si on fait pas une réforme des
retraites c'est qu'on passe on passe le
mistigri à ses enfants à ses
petits-enfants de la capitalisation qui
prendrait le dessus et donc si on
explique que vous transférer de cette
histoire là à vos petits-enfants là je
pense que il y a quand même c'est pas un
artifice c'est la présentation c'est la
vérité
c'est ça qui est important c'est fait
sur les retraites
Joker vers le silence en dit parfois
plus long Fanny vous doudou parler de
Davos on le disait en Suisse les grandes
entreprises des grands chefs de
multinationales sont réunis là-bas dans
la montagne suisse avec un message 200
millionnaires demandent à être plus taxé
et oui vous ne rêvez pas c'est assez
inattendu il plaide pour la mise en
place d'un impôt sur la fortune ils
évoquent la nécessité d'un
investissement pour notre bien commun je
cite pour un avenir meilleur alors c'est
200 millionnaires la plupart sont
étrangers il y a deux Français dont les
noms sont pas connus et alors Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'Économie ce matin a
saisi et l'occasion de leur répondre
dans l'écoute
alors pour une taxe du gouvernement ils
peuvent donner certains le font aux
États-Unis c'est dans la culture ou bien
alors aussi qu'ils peuvent changer leur
comportement parce que on sait que ce
sont les plus riches qui consomment le
plus qui prennent le plus souvent
l'avion et qui quelque part sont les
moins vertueux écologiquement parlants
alors cette demande elle fait écho à ce
que revendique femme depuis très
longtemps c'est vrai que c'est une
accélérée si elle en parle une ONG et
elle cible généralement Bernard Arnault
et c'est un très bon exemple l'homme le
plus riche de France à la tête de LVMH
gros groupe de luxe et c'est vrai que
quand on entend encore avant-hier que
LVMH plus grosse capitalisation
boursière à 400 milliards d'euros en
Europe capitalisation boursière ça veut
dire qu'il faudrait vendre toutes c'est
la somme de toutes les actions qu'on
vendrait on récolterait 400 milliards
d'euros mais justement Bernard Arnault
n'a pas 400 milliards d'euros sur ces
comptes et la valorisation boursière
c'est assez fluctuant assez volatile
demandé à Elon Musk il a perdu 200
milliards de dollars en quelques quand
la section Tesla est tombée et il faut
souvent faire aussi le distinguer entre
richesse personnelle patrimoine
personnel et puis richesse d'entreprise
souvent il y a une confusion entre les
la richesse ou ce que représente la
valeur de ces entreprises que dirige ces
grands ces grands et donc l'idée d'Oxfam
qui dit en gros si vous taxez les Ultra
riches à 2% ou financer les retraites
pour vous c'est ça semble un petit peu
simple
parce qu'il faut pas tomber dans la
démagogie j'aurais mis vient de le dire
le système de retraite que l'on défend
c'est un système par répartition alors
évidemment il manque un peu d'argent et
c'est sûr que si on en injectait il se
porterait mieux mais c'est un système
sur le long terme un système comme vous
le disiez Madame Bachelot sur des
générations donc ça ne réglerait
certainement pas les problèmes pour les
générations qui les enfants même là qui
sont en train de naître alors sans
prendre la défense des
ultra riches qui peuvent toujours faire
mieux parce que je crois que voilà et je
me pose la question
est-ce que ça formerait forcément une
société sans pauvre c'est aussi ça le
sujet vous avez entendu
sur les impôts CD il explique très bien
que le problème pour les plus pauvres ou
les classes moyennes c'est pas qu'il
existe des super riches a toujours été
c'est que finalement il y a 25 ou 30% de
la population parmi les plus élevés qui
captent la richesse et qui capte un
modèle ceux qui font monter l'immobilier
à Paris c'est pas Bernard Arnault ou
François Pinault ce qui installent qui
s'installe sur les côtes et qui
dépossettent de leur maison les gens qui
habitaient là c'est pas Bernard Arnault
c'est effectivement des gens les 25 35%
de Français qui peuvent s'offrir ces
maisons donc en fait pour la gauche
souvent attaquer les super riches c'est
refuser de voir ses propres ses propres
fautes pour garder
d'une société 100 milliardaires
Christophe guillui oui mais aussi Rosine
bachelots
merci d'avoir passé leur avec nous merci
les affranchis à demain Stéphanie
Depierre à demain à vous je l'espère
même mieux très belle soirée sur elle
c'est pas
[Musique]